I didn't know myself well enough when I
got married I didn't admit to myself
that the things that that I actually
wanted the things that I wanted and that
I still want I wasn't ballsy enough to
to let it be okay that I that I wanted
certain things and that certain things
were important to me I I grew up you
know Brazil has this sort of like
misogynistic kind of like you know male
dominance in relationships and and
culturally and I you know I left Brazil
when I was seven for the first time and
then ten for good and I didn't have that
as an example in my household my parents
were you know my mom real ballbuster so
my dad was the more like sedate one but
I I didn't also I also didn't have a
they got divorced when I was twenty I
didn't have an example of a one or a
great relationship my mom raised me to
go you know never cook for any man
you're gonna be successful you're not
gonna have kids until you were in your
30s or 40s you're always going to take
care of yourself first because this is
what she wanted for herself and she
filled me with all of this and I was
like this is what I want I am NOT gonna
cook for anyway I'm gonna be a feminist
I'm gonna and it wasn't really what I
wanted I didn't want to I didn't isn't I
mean is so hard right and this
like me to movement whatever but like I
don't want to be equal the same as my
man I think that there is a man and
there is a woman and I think that's okay
doesn't mean I should get paid less or
it doesn't mean that I should but we
don't do the same things and we don't
serve the same function in a household
and I think those roles can change and
they can be what they are for the right
relationship you know with who whatever
you want for yourself but I didn't
really know myself well enough to know
that I am much more traditional I
realized then I I wanted to be cooler
than I am